があったらあ
パッパッと始まっていた今日は外れ社長です
あっはぁあああ
はいおれの武器としてこの天才的な頭脳を越えずに立つのを使って夜はすごいこと今日
思いついた
君女子スマホよく使いますよねスマホなってる時は確実でて求めていけないって出てる
時も寝る時も触るときにこうするんですよ
歌割りで卵+前の力ユンジョためらったしちゃって一帯を保有することがあるよ
スマホねどうぞ
の使う時に手で持ったなきゃいけないから落とす可能性もあるし
それで壊しちゃうときもあるそこドルは諦めたスマートフォン用のクリップスタンド
ga 自在に曲がるフレキシブル r スマートによく妊婦さんですこれ使えばスマホ
たしたのにるりんぱって食べるんでねるりんぱっとなるとまず陥ることはないから安心
です
おっしゃ言ういう感じか采配
はいはいうおおおお
これかこういう感じですね買ったベレーでこれを
郡津恵乃はるとかに止めて交換開いてあげてこういう感じでスマホを固定しておくこと
ができます
それじゃあこれではうつる心配がないわけですた手でも見れるし
どこにもできるっていうちょっとすぐいいものなんですけどうれしい場合はなくスマホ
を触れるわけでございます
ちょっと便利だね素晴らしい
頭痛に素晴らしい
がーなるべくたくさん用意しました全部のアームを立つと6m 以上のなくなりなり
ます全員にスマホからドコでもね落ちることがなく水に使える空間を6メートル北の
藩邸内で作ることができるって言うけどバイアスフレッツ気に留めておくんですけども
井田だった上手夕方すまんをトゥリップサンドを作ってみようと思いますでは行こうよ
本当に大丈夫かが弱い地が住んだよ1個ねよとりあえずといいですね
大丈夫かの3つはなくだったんですけど結局これでいきましょう
めっちゃはたんだけどフレンドこんなのになるんだけどに可能アームが弱いと結局
下がってきちゃうんでやレタスやこれ大失敗ですよこれだって3個人がちょっと厳しい
ねちょっと厳しい givi ジビ初日日してきたけどやっぱ5位
スマホの腫れたうわぁ
予想外なんだけど面接前の時点で立つことがまず無理ぐらいのチコ弱さです
はああああ
わぁどうすればいいの無理じゃんお前も2つは2つで行こう
ちょっと半分にある二つを使って二つかませる時空を2つにすることでちょっと安定弾
強めます229関節ピエール的に行きましょうですこの2つにこれをくっつければ
とりあえず問題ナッシングですドア
ああああもう無理じゃんちょ待ってお振りじゃんねーじゃん
ただなってって
あーをしっかりしくらいお墓ちゃんと母さん狙うぬ親だってよええ
姫丸余興なまっすぐ謎の優しそう
抜くうもリオチェーンぶー
ひまわりではないですね煉獄のお花畑みたいになっちゃったんですけどまぁ多分無理
です
2個付けてももうこんな状況で所3つ目つけたらもうありますので3つでつけると思う
こうなっちゃうわけですよ根本的に無事だったこれ
これだけあれば濡れるんじゃまあこれだけあればと濡れず固まることによって強くなる
今回の方がこれをしたかったんだ黒で止まるわけだ
ごめんみんな俺勘違いしてた俺が本当にしたいことはスマートフォンを自由に見ること
じゃない
そう俺のしたいことはこのクリップさあの上に ping が通る子
いけるでしょ目がちょっと集まれば強いこんな技頑丈なんだずっ帯域量
ています
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
r
おっん
しています